500 years ago ferdinand magellan was the
first European to sail around the
southern tip of South America
it's an icy climate here and also home
to the Magellanic penguins named after
the Spanish explorer and Raya Raya Rey
has ventured down here to Tierra del
Fuego to do some exploring herself she's
a biologist from Argentina southern
center for scientific research
she and her team make regular trips to
the remote colonies of penguins here
seven in total we're on our way to isla
martillo hammer island the colony there
has around 5,000 pairs of magellanic
penguins and 50 pairs of Gentoo penguins
the colony has been around since the
1970s but we only started observing it
in the 90s and since then it's been
growing there continuously the seas are
calm today enabling the researchers to
bring their equipment on land without
any further problems the penguins don't
seem bothered by the visitors there are
several species living here together on
the island
Andrea ray has won an award for her
insights into the impact of humans on
the birds Magellanic penguins dig their
nests burrows in the ground
this is where they lay their eggs and
raise their young but the birds very
survival is influenced by human activity
rising sea temperatures have changed
marine food chains for the Penguins
it means hunting longer for food which
in turn means leaving their young alone
for longer and increasing their
vulnerability to seagulls and other
predators
no sooner okay southern rockhopper
penguins are among the species hardest
hit by climate change they need very
small types of prey such as larvae which
are themselves most susceptible to
changes in the temperature of the water
so the Penguins derive less energy from
their food and that has a long-term
impact on the population and Rhea Rhea
and her team are installing an automatic
monitoring system for the Penguins they
fitted some of the birds with a special
chip a sensor records their movement in
order to track general activity across
the colony penguins do look rather
helpless on land at least but they're
excellent divers and swimmers some
Magellanic penguins make it all the way
to Uruguay and Brazil covering a
distance of four thousand kilometers the
penguin Osan senthenil penguins are
guardians of the ocean they're also a
gauge of how healthy the marine
ecosystems are examining their food
intake how far they swim to find that
food and their reproductive rate enables
us to see how these species which are
dependent on the ocean are faring
penguins go on shore to mate and raise
their young an extremely sensitive phase
of their lives which is under threat
from growing pollution their nesting
holes are increasingly filled with
plastic waste which mainly comes from
the nearby city of Oshawa Illinois in
the Parthian toilet 90% of the nests
contain plastic way
as do the animal stomachs and feces see
currents and winds carry the plastic to
places you might think were untouched by
human activity four years ago
residents of Oshawa teamed up to tackle
the trash situation a blot on the entire
city coastline the initiative was
launched by Mya Muriel who was appalled
by the pollution brought to this remote
city by the wind and by sea currents
whenever you see stray dogs tearing
apart the garbage looking for food it
belongs in a landfill but a lot of it
ends up on streets across the city then
the birds come and pick away at the rest
I mean be Connie Robin la basura we've
gotten used to burying the garbage
sometimes when the snow arrives in
winter the trash is just left on the
beach and when snow melts the trash ends
up in the sea o shahe is called the gate
to the Antarctic the half a million
tourists who descend on Tierra del Fuego
every year posed a further threat to the
largely untouched ecosystem in 2005
andrea ray founded a group bringing
together citizens initiatives and local
tour operators what they want to see as
better management of the tourism sector
says the group's coordinators Sabrina
Koosman pasamos aware and polka simian
there's been a rise in tourism
especially in the number of boats with
tourist trips out to the sea or the
canal yeah there's the improper behavior
there are boats going too close to the
islands and using loudspeakers in the
vicinity of the animals
- lol asila homie I will not tourism at
one with nature tourism that's in
harmony with nature is always welcome
it's one of the human activities that
can help the most to conserve the
environment
above all so that the populations the
communities and the ecosystem remain as
pristine as possible
Dino possibly for the Penguins that
would bring some welcome relief in this
struggle for survival here in what is
called the end of the world